el ciclón Freddy ha asombrado a los
meteorólogos por su duración y ferocidad
se formó en las costas de Australia a
comienzos de febrero ahora más de un mes
después continúa haciendo estragos en
Madagascar mozambique pero sobre todo en
malawi en donde ha causado la muerte de
casi 200 personas en dicho país de
África Oriental ha destrozado carreteras
derrumbado puentes y se ha llevado a su
paso una enorme cantidad de
infraestructura y hogares Mira esta área
estaba llena de casas toda la área aquí
desde allá arriba y la gente desapareció
la gente desapareció las cosas
desaparecieron todo desapareció
Mientras tanto los familiares hacen
largas filas para reconocer a sus seres
queridos muchos son puestos en ataúdes
con las carreteras cortadas y la
dificultad de entrar en distintas zonas
del país las labores de rescate se
complican y los residentes y las fuerzas
de seguridad se unen para buscar a los
desaparecidos
una niña estaba metida hasta la cabeza
en el barro estaba pidiendo ayuda a
gritos Aunque el agua bajaba muy fuerte
logramos cruzar y rescatarla fue muy
difícil pero logramos sacarla
en malawi los hospitales están
desbordados según alertó médicos Sin
fronteras solo el centro de salud
la región más afectada recibió más de
200 heridos la organización ha alertado
sobre un posible aumento de casos de
cólera en un momento en el que el país
ya lucha contra el brote más mortífero
de su historia